Before the discovery of matches and other
modern conveniences, fires had to be started
in more primitive ways. Like rubbing sticks
together, or burning wood with a magnifying
glass. But anyone who's tried these methods
know it's extremely hard work to make a fire,
especially in an emergency situation. Luckily,
there's a way to cheat, and it's called "Char Cloth."
To get started on this project, I'll sacrifice
one of my little boys shirts, and a can of
tuna. This shirt is 100% cotton, and that's
what we need, so now we can focus prepping
this can. I'll grab my wife's can opener and
a small screwdriver and get to work on removing
the lid. The "lid lifter" cuts sideways, and
removes the top portion of the lid just below
the rim, and that's perfect because we'll
want it to fit back together later on. Ok,
the tuna comes out, and after a little cleaning,
our char cloth maker is nearly complete. Let's
cut off about 4 pieces of shirt and lay them
on the lid, then the bottom of the can fits
over top. To finish, we can punch a small
hole in the top with this screwdriver to act
as a vent hole. To char this cloth properly,
we'll need to heat this up over 400 degrees
Celsius, and that can be done with the Solar
Scorcher. It's about 7pm and the sun has nearly
set. I've found the focal point and am happy to see there's
still plenty of heat. The little flame shows
that the cotton is charing and releasing hydrogen
and methane gasses through the hole in the
top. Alright, the flame just went out, so
that means it's done, and we'll need to carefully
cover the hole with some aluminum foil to
prevent air from leaking in and causing a
flashback. Now that it's cooled down, we can
remove the foil and the cover to see how our
cloth turned out. It's completely black. Totally
charred, but not burned, and that's just what
we needed. The fabric's still pliable, but
is now extremely sensitive to heat. Just a
few seconds with the sun and a water bottle,
and we can easily make a fire! Your water bottle can also be used to make a fire without the char cloth but
it takes a lot longer, and is much more difficult. Ok, so it's the next day and I'm making another
batch, this time with an open flame! This
method works super well and only takes about
2 minutes to cook all the gasses out of the
fabric. When it's cooled down and the foil
is off, i'm really impressed at how much the
fabric has shrunk from the original size.
Now I'm wondering if cotton balls will work,
so my little boy is helping load a batch,
and after 2 minutes in the fire they're all
done. They're looking great and I'm interested
to see how they'll compare to the cotton fabric.
To test the quality, let's brush the side
with a flame, and blow gently to see if it
glows. Success! This fabric ignites amazingly
fast, and burns impressively slowly. From
this point, all it takes to get a flame is
to add something flammable, like this paper,
and blow. Haha FIRE! These charred cotton
balls work so well, and are so cheap and accessible,
that I think from now on I'm going to use
them exclusively in my Fire Piston. You can see how to build this in a different video.
I also tried making Char Cloth using another
fabric and a mint tin, a glass baby food jar,
and an Altoids tin. Overall, I was most impressed
with my tuna can, an open flame, and a handful
of cotton balls. Well there's another item
for my emergency kit and a fun project with
my kids. That's it for now. If you liked this
project, perhaps you'll like some of my others.
Check them out at www.thekingofrandom.com